all right it's movie retrospective time
once again yeah for the third week in a
row and I swear did not do this on
purpose we're doing a vampire baby
yeah because remember we did Fright
Night last week and then we did twins of
you all the week the week before that
yes I didn't mean to do like three
vampire maybe this was Lost Boys 1987 I
haven't seen this in a long time it's a
classic man 87 was the year I graduated
from high school yeah I'm always getting
this one and Fright Night confused when
I shouldn't do that any because I just
saw them yeah no I still would get a
confused look we watched him on the same
night actually I watched a nighttime in
that first Psalm I saw him kind of close
together yeah you know what I mean even
though they came out like two years
apart just about and I still saw him
kind of close together I probably rented
him I didn't see I don't think I didn't
see him in the theater yeah and you know
so I kind of get some of the facts jump
jumbled you know in between the two and
I straighten them back out once I
straighten them out I remember but left
to my own devices I kind of remember
these movies as the same movie yeah yeah
which is interesting because they're
really I mean obviously they're very
different but yeah they're both vampire
movies but other than that there's
really not a lot similar to them you
know they're both like teen-oriented I
guess but that's pretty much the only
similarities they have kind of ours they
have kind of a different tone I mean
Lost Boys I mean Fright Night I would
call that a horror comedy even though it
had some scary stuff in it um Lost Boys
I guess is more like a horror adventure
even though it does have some humor in
it too although I don't think I would
call it up horror comedy straight out
Fright Night kind of felt like a
throwback movie like something out of a
you know out of like you know et or you
know sometimes ya know Berg move well it
only came out three years after yeah and
Lost Boys felt like a more modern movie
that felt like something you might see
in 92 yeah or 93 well the interesting
thing about it I think I mentioned this
when we were talking about fright night
was that prior to Fright Night coming
out I feel like vampire movies I mean
other than the hunger but that was more
like a cult film that wasn't like a big
like blockbuster or anything like that I
do feel like vampires were like seen as
like Creek
the old-fashioned monsters because yes
and rice had written the vampire
you know the first trilogy of The
Vampire Chronicles or whatever but they
hadn't made the movies out of them yeah
person really didn't know him so yeah so
that yeah there was still much you know
kind of like a Saltine type of thing so
so I feel like Fright Night kind of
showed that vampires could be done well
again whereas the lost boys made
vampires cool again and this was
definitely and I think even Joss Whedon
has said this outright this was
definitely the inspiration for Buffy the
Vampire Slayer yes I know it was based
on a movie that had Kristy Swanson a
pee-wee Herman in it but the TV show the
tone of the TV show even some of the
characters like spike and stuff like
that from Buffy the Vampire Slayer was
taken more or less from The Lost Boys
you know because it had such a I mean it
had a huge cultural impact really I mean
I remember how old was I in 87 I was
probably 16 maybe 15 or 16 about 18 yeah
because I think I had just started high
school on 87 and this was huge like
especially among kind of like goth kids
and punk kids and [ __ ] like that this
was the first time we had seen anything
like this in that kind of genre I mean
other than that was this big of a hit
you know I mean that was like a big
cultural phenomenon yeah there'd been
like return to living dead and stuff
like that that had Punk's in it movie
had a very California feel - oh yeah
even though you know I don't know where
it was I don't remember where it was set
well it was shot in Santa Cruz okay
because they weren't allowed to call it
that isn't any kind of like a waterfront
suburban type area something like maybe
like Malibu is what it's supposed to
yeah like I think if it was pretty cool
you know it was good it had a
good-looking cast like you said all you
know everybody was all sexy as a
[ __ ] you know for the time you
know all the vampires look like
something modern yeah Molly crew or even
like you know it looked like something
out of guns and roses you know you had
you had Ted or was it bill
yeah Alex winter house went yeah from
bill & ted's nice market long blonde
hair and you had all the Feldman's were
in it there's only one but I thought
there was like 200 there Cory was their
first name all right Cory hey dude the
Cory's that's what they that's yeah you
know it was just good flick it's real
like I said it sounded good good oh yeah
and I use this I had the soundtrack on
cassette back in the day particularly
because I was I mean back in the mid 80s
I was like a huge fan of echo and the
Bunnymen fun fact that was also the
first band I ever saw live yeah so I was
a big fan of theirs and obviously they
did a cover of the doors people are
strange for this movie that one song
they still play that the club down here
cry little sister was probably the
biggest by Gerard McMahon I think his
name is Jarret Gerrard or Gerald I can't
remember McMahon yep pretty epic they've
done like a bunch of remixes of it and
stuff and that was kind of like the
biggest hit from it I mean but this had
some great it had like an INXS song with
hip INXS and Jimmy Barnes it was like
another Australian rock singer they had
that lost in the shadow song which was
actually the dude from foreigner did
that song too and the very famous muscle
bound oily saxophone guy who I didn't
realize this until I looked it up later
his name I think is Tim Capello at the
time that he was in The Lost Boys he was
actually touring with Tina Turner's band
so he wasn't like a nobody or anything
so Sophie saw him live just a couple
months back yeah
so I'm live in Detroit or in the Detroit
area that the goth club there she's she
called him muscle saxophone man he she
took some pictures of them and she looks
just like he did it's funny because had
she just been in Tina Turner's band like
no one would remember him but because of
that like 30 seconds seen in the last
Boys now everybody remember say if he's
supposed to be awesome like that she
said he was awesome life and you know
it's you know it kicks ass I was doing
like some research about this cuz
apparently and I'll get into it in a bit
but you know there have been some comic
books that have like continued the story
of the Lost Boys
and in some of them that guy is like a
major character which I thought was kind
of rad that they like kind of wove him
into the story because he was such an
iconic part of yeah he's not forgettable
even though he was only in it for like
maybe 30 seconds we don't expect it it
looks fake yeah you don't expect a
bodybuilder to be you know musically
talented yeah dude the second you know
he's one of the songs on the soundtrack
as well oh yeah
and so if you said live he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] blew the doors off blue blew the
door I bet he did it everybody loved it
I bet he did yeah like I said he made a
huge impression of this movie because
everybody [ __ ] remembers that every
review I've ever seen of this movie they
mentioned in particularly yeah but yeah
so the interesting thing now if you
haven't seen the Lost Boys this is
another one of those movies which is
like what the [ __ ] is the matter with
you I mean even if you didn't grow up in
the 80s you know which we did um
everybody in the 80s that grew up in the
80s saw the [ __ ] Lost Boys and even
it seems like subsequently like a lot of
younger generations just because it's
such an iconic it's really one of the
most iconic movies of the 80s yeah you
know it's funny what's that watching it
a couple days back when we saw this is I
haven't seen this since the 80s I really
appreciated the movie yeah it was a lot
better than I remembered oh yeah at the
time that I saw it it didn't really make
a huge impression yeah it was just
another one of the movies you know I
mean II watched it didn't and like I
said it just kind of kind of blurred
together with Fright Night yeah it's
back in those days was just another one
of the movies you know I mean that's the
way I saw well it's like another one of
the decent movies yeah I mean not well
not it's not like a bad movie that you
forget about yeah and it wasn't like a
terrible movie that you can't forget it
was just I could move that you watch
well yeah yeah it's pretty good yeah
good because I don't know I just we were
more spoiled back then I think what
though I guess although I probably was
going pretty strong at that time I have
to say maybe because of its kind of like
whole rock and roll narrative and plus
like I was very into like goth stuff and
vampires and that just kind of hold look
of it I think it made a bigger
impression
it probably made a bigger impression on
me than it made on you maybe because I
mean I saw it a million times when
interview with the vampire came out but
that one kind of took the [ __ ] crown
and and I'd forgotten all about the
other vampire movies but looking at him
now it's there it was about on par a
very different story
yeah but about on par with the interview
of the vampire movie in terms of just
you know quality yeah yeah although like
I said I think my story I feel like The
Lost Boys had more it's definitely a
horror movie but it does have a lot more
humor in it let's talk in California
rock'n'roll in California kind of a
scene movie yeah it was it definitely
had that aspect right you know guys mom
was cool and you know the Davis just
kind of had that kind of like that
Spielberg in context to it you know you
you know I haven't haven't grown up
until the age of about 13 in California
you know it when you see it yeah even
back in 87 you know I gonna look at it
now that's the way old California kata
was or that was the image it wanted to
portray it wasn't like that everywhere
in California yeah well like I said if
you haven't seen it just the gist of the
story is you have two brothers they're
both teenagers named Michael and Sam who
are played by Jason Patrick who's the
older brother and Sam he's played by
Corey Haim is the younger brother their
mom Lucy played by Dianne Wiest - fun
fact had just won an Oscar for Woody
Allen's Hannah and her sister whether
that was a Woody Allen movie wouldn't
hate her sisters yeah she had just what
she had just won an Oscar for that and
it was apparently really excited to be
in being a horror movie so I thought
that was pretty neat so she plays their
mom she just got divorced and she's
broke she lost her job and everything
like that so she's moving to this town
this beachside town Santa Carla to move
back in with her eccentric dad grandpa
who lives in like this weird old cabin
with like all these like like animals
that he has stuffed like beavers and
whatnot
and he kind of looks like he looks like
a really old hippie but also with a
little bit of a Charles Manson kind of
leather face got a flair I guess I don't
know a bad as Bruce Dern though no
that's true he's not quite as crazies
but but along that same continuum so so
they're moving to this fictional town
Santa Carla
but like I said if anybody's from you
know California you will recognize the
boardwalk and everything immediately
because particularly there's one roller
coaster there called the the dipper or
something like that that's really really
famous and it is Santa Cruz now
apparently they really wanted to shoot
this in Santa Cruz but because of this
whole thing the fictional town and the
in the movie it's like supposed to like
the murder capital of the world
Santa Cruz was like yeah not so much we
don't really want that kind of
reputation even though it was true
because at that time when they filmed
that Santa Cruz had had like 30 serial
murders that was Edward Edmund Kemper
and there was a couple other serial
killers running around at that time so
there were a lot of murders going on in
this yes
California was the Florida of this of
the eighties yeah so but you know
understandably they said when they did
like the contract for like the locations
shooting and stuff they said you can
shoot it here but you can't call it
Santa Cruz you have to call it something
else so they called it Santa Carla so
they moved there the older brother
Michael starts falling in with a crowd
of a local biker gang I guess you could
call him because he's fallen in love
with this girl star that he sees on the
pier and it turns out spoiler alert
that this biker gang are all vampires
yeah and slowly Turk start turning
Michael in Dillon as well and being a
writer myself these are not what you
would actually call bikers though well
to be a biker you actually have to have
Harley's these guys just wrote they were
right riding supermoto 's yeah they were
they were kind of like cyclists vampires
they were a mud David they were a little
gang of motor they're a little gang they
were had motorcycles yeah yeah
they weren't bikers yeah they I should
also mention to that also in here like I
said when the whole vampire shenanigans
start to occur there are also two
brothers the Frog brothers Edgar and
Alan whose hippie hippie parents are
perpetually stoned and sleeping on this
big famous comic book store and these
two know that Santa Carla is full of
vampires and they styled themselves kind
of like a vampire killers and are trying
to recruit Sam into
like vampire-killing business yeah which
I thought was very funny yeah I remember
I remember when I first saw that I
actually liked those characters the best
out of all they were because that was
kind of a [ __ ] that being my buddies
would do yeah it was very relatable yeah
and like I said the funny thing about it
too well one I have to say that the
director Joel Schumacher which I'll get
into that in a minute to but he
basically told the Frog brothers he's
like I want you guys like they're
teenagers but he's like I want you guys
go watch all the Sylvester Stallone and
Chuck Norris movies because I want you
guys to be like Rambo or like real like
Rambo and Chuck Norris he wanted them to
be like but like he's like play it
completely straight like don't not funny
or anything like that but you're just
completely serious about you or a
vampire-killing badass and like you
really do think that so it works really
well like from a comedic point of view
because they take it very seriously yeah
they weren't like there weren't like
sixties seventies and eighties Armiger
gear yeah one of them's got [ __ ]
Vietnam Tiger strife Special Forces
Tigers strike uh-huh arrange your stuff
yeah I've got [ __ ] Army Ranger outfit
on and a lot of it's but it's
interesting too because a lot of the
like later um a comic book series that
were spun off of this movie there's a
whole series just called like the Frog
brothers or something like that it's
about them yeah and they were actually
characters in the later sequels to him
which we'll get into a little bit too
now one thing that I found very
interesting about the Lost Boys when it
was first conceived the woman that wrote
the original screenplay that was her in
this writing partner of hers that she
had and their idea and the reason that
it's called the Lost Boys is because
they were doing a riff on Peter Pan they
got into a discussion about you know how
Peter Pan he only appears at night he
can fly and he never grows old and then
the writing partner was like oh that's
and jokes maybe oh it's because he's a
vampire so the woman that wrote the
original screenplay was like hey that's
a really good idea and she really liked
the idea of like child vampires so the
original conception of the movie was the
vampires The Lost Boys the gang
they were only supposed to be like 12 or
13 years old and the Frog brothers who
were fighting them were only supposed to
be eight they were supposed to be like
two Cub Scouts okay this was supposed to
be more like the Goonies right because
the Goonies had just come out like a
year or two before and it was like
hugely successful and the first drafts
of the screenplay they actually tried to
get Richard Donner who directed The
Goonies they wanted him to direct it
because it was posed to be like kid
vampires because in the movie the the
Frog brothers are probably more like 16
17 yeah they're yeah they're more like
middle teenage in here yeah and then the
the gang are obviously supposed to be
like in their late teens or early
twenties even they're probably the
actors who are a bit older but yeah
they're supposed to be like older
teenagers okay or in their early 20s but
then it kind of got as the you know
script kind of got worked on and [ __ ]
like that I mean the original script did
like result in a bidding war so people
did really want it but when it got
bought I believe it was by Warner
Brothers and they started shopping in
around different directors I think Mary
Lambert who directed Pet Sematary
she was attached at one point and I it
might have been her idea or somebody
else's idea that's like can we go a
little bit older you know to make them
older teenagers that would be a better
story and [ __ ] like that so you know the
production company thought that was a
better idea and then they decided
because like I said they originally
Richard Donner was going to direct it
but then he decided to go and directly
sell weapon so they actually got Joel
Schumacher who had he has kind of a bad
reputation now mostly because of Batman
and Robin which was a terrible terrible
movie yeah pretty much any measure but
you have to think this was before that
had happened he had just made st. Elmo's
fire which was hugely successful he
would get he did falling down he did
Flatliners a couple years later which we
reviewed so he did had done some good
films he hadn't like started going down
the toilet although in his defense there
wasn't much he could do with Batman
Robin true based on what they were
asking him to do and what honey and then
all the characters that they gave him to
work with mean how the hell are you
gonna make a movie out of all that and
the thing about I mean I guess I know
it's easy
- just point the finger at one person
like the director yes the director is in
charge of how the movie is going to come
out and [ __ ] like that but movies are a
collaborative effort between like
hundreds and hundreds of people and then
they had in the head Arnold in there and
Arnold was contractually he could not be
a villain but they had him as mr. freeze
how do they you know fulfill that how do
they make mr. freeze a good guy yeah
which I guess they kind of did at the
end it's just I don't even I've blocked
most of yeah because even now like Smosh
sides at the very end and that yeah I've
seen it but it's like now it's like I
just see like clips of it and I'm just
like oh god that may be say about it was
so bad yeah but like I said this this
was prior to that happening so Joel
Schumacher's name wasn't mud at this
point so he actually did turn in a
decent movie and it was his idea like I
said they'd already had the idea to like
make the vampires older and make the
Frog brothers older but he was kind of
like okay well I want to like sexy it up
I want the vampires to be like really
cool I want everybody in this movie I'd
be like really good-looking so for some
of the vampire gang he got like some of
the more models and [ __ ] like that
actually for the character of star he
wanted to get initially he wanted like
quote-unquote a blond waifish woman but
when they cast Jason Patric as Michael
he had just worked with Jami Gertz on
solar babies and he kind of had a little
bit of a crush on her so he's like hey
why don't you put her in the movie so
she came in auditioned and they put her
in the movie Kiefer Sutherland I believe
he was asked outright to be the main
vampire David because this is one of his
best movies actually yes he is foxy as
[ __ ] in this I have to say um and again
we play an opposite to him the the good
guy what was Michael yes my Jason
Patrick yeah you can tell they're trying
to get you to draw a connection between
this guy and and Jim Morrison there's a
lot of Jim Morrison they got the same
haircut they show him with that haircut
and then they [ __ ] cut back and look
at all Kiefer Sullivan and behind him in
the background is
the poster widget moremore seeing the
same haircut they're trying to get you
it and then they're playing door songs
and stuff they try to get you to think
that the main character is Jim Morrison
and he kind of does he folk Jim Morrison
he does a bit yeah it was walking stuff
and yeah well like I said they were
really want you more finish kind of
character yeah because you have to think
I mean I remember particularly in the
late 80s a lot of that kind of love 60s
music particularly the doors and Pink
Floyd and stuff like that was making a
big huge comeback because I remember a
lot of dudes in my high school we just
listened to it going yeah going way back
and like listen to that stuff what's
outdoors it was almost like the original
goth band in a certain way it was yeah
Velvet Underground oh yeah but I
definitely remember being in high school
and a lot of people like wearing tie-dye
and like having Jim Morrison shirts and
Jimi Hendrix
yeah so that was like a big thing at
that time some of the darker Rolling
Stones yeah stuff was good but yeah
there was a lot of that Governor yeah
you know there was some kind of proto
goth going on in the 60s Oh for real
yeah but yeah so Kiefer Sutherland like
I said I think he'd only been he was in
at close range which i think was where
Joel Schumacher had seen him and you
know asked him to be in this movie
because he thought he'd make a really
good villain and we're just prior to
this he had done stand by me who also
played a villain in that he played a ace
Merrill I think it was like the big
bully or whatever so this was one of his
like very early roles and like I said he
looks great in this movie I mean yes
this movie is very 80s like I guess it
doesn't it does scream 80s to me but
maybe not as much as it would to
somebody that didn't grow up in the
eighties because I remember when people
used to wear that kind of [ __ ] I
remember when this was very late
eighties though that it I remember when
this was cool when like kind of
punk-rock II people had Kiefer
Sutherland's kind of hair even though
nowadays it's a mullet it's essentially
a mullet it's towards the end of the 80s
towards the end of the 80s you started
seeing stuff like punk rock and certain
kinds of hard rock and metal kind of
emerging yeah if you looked at Motley
Crue early Motley Crue it kind
goth if you looked at you know you
started to see shades of damn guns and
roses and things and I mean they kind of
had a little bit yeah very glam yeah but
it was kind of blending together in the
same thing now went on all the way
through the early 90s and really to me I
watched the movie the other time the
last time I saw it I realized how early
90s it looked yeah because that started
to become more mainstream in that first
half of the 90s with you know kind of
like the underground scene I did yeah I
think I do remember when I was saying
before like I think I said on one of our
other shows or reviews or something like
that about how I feel like in the early
90s when alternative music our punk
music and stuff like that started to go
mainstream I you know yes it seemed like
it happened like really quickly but I
think it might have started in the mid
to late 80s and I think this movie might
have been one another peg along that
yeah route and you look at this movie
kind of visually the palette and
everything in just the way this movie is
edited and it kind of reminds me of a
bit of Flatliners and that's what's the
same director same director yes that
called it yeah it's the same that's why
so this kind of style went what's name
what's the name of the director again
Joel Schumacher Schumacher yeah okay
yeah you could definitely tell yeah you
can definitely tell because I was
watching I was like man from I see a lot
of Flatliners away yeah because it's a
pretty movie Flatliners gorgeous oh yeah
and you know so this one's looks good -
yeah the lighting in this one is like
really cool like so there's a lot of
scenes filmed like by firelight and yeah
you know it's like everything's foggy
and like no tragedy he's kind of doing
things where he's kind of evoking
evoking Cana dam the the look of
stained-glass even though it may not be
stained-glass might be posters in the
background but we brought in Flatliners
and instead of posters it would be like
stained glass yeah you know I mean the
way he puts something in the background
colors in the background is just way he
does stuff and it's in like a dark room
with down candle that candle lit red or
orange light or red light
very warm Corellia so it's it's a cool
palette I like to wait I like the way
both those movies look yeah this one in
particular it's almost like kind of like
I mean I guess he did like a warm as
he's trying to evoke like you know fire
the cold beachy thing blood you know all
that kind of stuff so he did really seem
to like think about how he wanted it to
look and I have to say too that the the
underground layer that the vampire gang
lives in which you know Kiefer
Sutherland his character's name David he
explains in the course of the movie that
this used to be like some big like fancy
hotel a resort or something back on the
beach like he says 80 or 85 years ago
and it fell into a crack during an
earthquake and now there's like the ruin
of it is kind of underground in this
cave and they live in it and that hole I
that was one of my favorite things about
the movie because I said oh man I wish
had a big [ __ ] underground lair like
that I could [ __ ] live in and [ __ ]
now that was actually a set that was a
set and Grandpa's cabin was a set the
rest of the [ __ ] was filmed just around
Santa Cruz you know on the boardwalk and
you know just other locations I think
that didn't Jordan peels us I'm pretty
sure they also shot that on the Santa
Cruz Boardwalk as an homage to the Lost
Boys I think they did well all I know is
that I didn't quite appreciate the movie
when it came out and the quality because
I saw it on television on a VHS tape
through it through CRT screen but you
look at it now and blu-ray quality on a
donut good screens that we have today
this is how it would have looked in the
theater it looks good it looks really
good and that um the writing's good it
is like I said it has I think one of the
best things about it like I said it has
comedic it has like a lot of comedic
moments particularly with the with Corey
Haims character and the Frog brothers
who are very funny even though like I
said they play everything straight so
there's like funny [ __ ] in it but it's
not a comedy no it's just something bout
the tone that those directors could
evoke back then they its kind of lacking
today I don't know it's just it's a hard
thing to get right because I mean I make
sure so many elements yeah gather and
they're not doing it all like they used
to
yeah they do it differently now I mean I
did see some movies in the 80s
tried to kind of strike that balance and
also failed like I said it's a very
difficult thing to get it's it's hard
you know look at something like gremlins
which is funny but also kind of scare
it's kind of like a monster movie and
it's kind of like dark and [ __ ] like
that that's a very hard tone to get
right it's also kind of colorful yeah
and it may have had something to it the
film stock that they used in the cameras
that they use there's definitely the
lighting but there's something about and
then how they dressed everyone yeah you
know I mean everyone's costumes are what
they were wearing is really well planned
out for all these shots I mean it
happens by accident
everything in those in in movies like
this is just kind of orchestrated to
evoke a certain emotional reaction that
you don't really get into you see it on
the big screen or you see it in really
good HD quality on these new screens
that we have now but just in VHS and in
a little aspect ratio everything looked
like it looked like it looked terrible
when I saw so when you seen it now you
know stream into that big [ __ ] TV
good TV that we have it looks great I
mean you know I I didn't realize what I
was missing you know you didn't get that
experience back in the 80s and unless
you went to the movie unless you went to
the movies now this Fright Night I did
not see in the theater Lost Boys I did I
did see Lost Boys in the theater and
then subsequently like I saw it a bunch
of more times because I think I bought
it on VHS or I taped it up HBO or
something like that so this is another
one I don't think I saw it quite as many
times as Fright Night but almost because
when we watched it again I remembered
pretty much every single scene in every
single line from this [ __ ] movie now
apparently and I haven't seen them so
I'm not gonna comment I'm just gonna
tell you what other people have said
there were two sequels to this now I
should say that actually Joel Schumacher
because this movie was actually very
successful it only costs eight eight and
a half million to make ended up making
35 million at the box office in another
14 million on home video and at was
actually I think the most rented movie
of 1988 or one of the top ten most
rented movies in 1988 so it so it was a
big deal so Joel Schumacher wanted to
make a sequel and it was going to be
called The Lost Girls
David's character Kiefer Sutherland was
actually going to reprise his role
because he was going to argue oh well at
the end of the first Lost Boys yes he
got impaled on the antlers but it didn't
go through his heart so he could have
lived he didn't blow up or anything like
some of the other vampires did so they
were gonna bring him back but now he was
gonna be in with like another biker gang
but they were all going to be girls so
it was gonna be a similar thing but they
were gonna bring back you know the Frog
brothers never liked them but it never
worked out they said they worked on it
for years and years like for a couple
years after the first Lost Boys came out
and it just never came to fruition it
was in development hell and [ __ ] like
that but then 20 years later they beta
sequel they went direct to DVD and it
was called The Lost Boys the tribe the
only recurring character was Corey
Feldman who reprised his role as one of
the Frog brothers and I have heard it
was not very good I have not seen it but
it looked a lot like people that have
seen it that they're like well it just
looked like a modern vampire look it
looked like Twilight or like they were
trying to evoke Twilight so it wasn't
really all that successful I was saying
yeah they yeah and nothing that they'll
do is they'll trying to make things look
too realistic yeah and it just kind of
kind of spoils kind of spoils going to a
movie
there's something about a movie a movies
very much like like a theater
productions well yeah be you know so our
generation just kind of kind of enjoyed
that kind of weird theatrical almost
kind of artificial look although I have
to say that movie I have to say that the
practical effects in Lost Boys are
actually really good like all the bangs
are good like they had all the really
cool content somebody looks really
awesome talk about the lighting and the
color that's not normal yeah you don't
go walk around it you don't walk around
in real life and see this [ __ ] like that
I wish yeah you could tell that
everything is kind of laid out by an
interior decorator and somebody who knew
everything about camera lighting yeah
everything looked beautiful the reality
isn't like that
well yeah hammering a normal pin just
ran in place and it somewhere in the
earth just a boring gray well yeah why
do you I mean why do you think the
original Suspiria
is one of my favorite movies ever
because it's just like visually orgasms
yeah it's like you can see I don't even
have to have the like [ __ ] volume on
I could just look at it yeah because
it's beautiful you know a lot of these
moves today they they look - they look
like they're actually happening yeah
yeah that's the thing but like I said I
kind of like you know the I guess in the
indie world like you know when I keep
bringing up that movie the lighthouse
but it's like you know what I mean it's
like you can see like people are trying
to do other things with it so you don't
yeah so you don't just that obviously
was like that obviously wasn't happening
either just the aspect ratio everything
is black and white it just well yeah we
that was on grainy film stock like old
fashioned [ __ ] it was reality I think we
shot it on 16 millimeter reality doesn't
look like that yeah and if you were just
standing there watching that happen
those those two those guys know a house
do not [ __ ] yeah give you the same
impact well yeah yeah but yeah so am
impact okay so either because the movie
wasn't good or because it went to DVD or
because they waited 20 [ __ ] years
like to make a sequel to the Lost Boys
Lost Boys the tribe like I said it's got
pretty shitty reviews however it only
costs four million dollars to make and
it made eight million dollars back so of
course they made a third one called The
Lost Boys the thirst and they actually
got Corey Feldman back for that one and
the other guy that played I can't
remember the Jameson neulander that's
the other actors named the other actor
that played the other frog brother so
they were both in the third one I've
heard the third one was slightly better
than the second one but still not that
great and it didn't really do all that
well however as I said there have been
at least one maybe two like um a comic
book you know series that were you know
if spun off of the movie one of them is
actually the artwork and it is like
really really gorgeous and like I said
they even like they have another
character that's like that was sired by
David and the Frog brothers come back in
it like I said the the oily saxophone
guy is like a main character so I
thought that was kind of cool that they
incorporated him into the story so he
wasn't just like some random guy played
saxophone on the stage on the beach I
thought that was kind of neat but yeah
so
so you know what I mean it's like this
is one of those movies that it was
probably one of the formative movies of
my teenage years like I said I think
this came out the first year that I was
in high school and I went and saw it in
the theater and I loved it I mean I had
the soundtrack on cassette I had like
posters from it and [ __ ] like that
I thought Kiefer Sutherland was just
like super super cool in this and it's
like I just wanted to be a vampire and
live in that big and [ __ ] cave and
all this other kind of [ __ ] it's just
there was so much about it especially at
that time period yeah I was a senior at
that time that I was in Brazil actually
yeah yeah but there you know there was
so much about it that just like struck a
chord like with people my age well it
was a special movies one-of-a-kind it
was its own thing kind of like it's hard
to duplicate that magic like yeah like
you can't duplicate Terminator 1 you
can't duplicate predator 1 yeah well
it's it it's just because yeah and I
think that it's that it's the you know
that people have a hard time doing that
everything because when is any sequel
they just as good as the first one it
hardly ever is they're just like there's
maybe less than a handful of examples
they're bad ideas if you want to destroy
it if you want to destroy a good idea
make a sequel to it I know yeah but you
know that it's a cash grab yes that they
want more the money is just there like
this made so much money it's like even
if it only makes half of that much money
that's still a lot imagine if they did
wanted to do Titanic - ok how do we how
do we bring this how we bring the team
do you know I I would bet you a
substantial sum of money that that
meeting happened oh sure that somebody
at least brought it up and that would
have destroyed Titanic ones really yeah
I wouldn't destroy his reputation I mean
it'd be like I'll [ __ ] Titanic I mean I
obviously didn't get made yet but it
might Titanic - but I then you're
falling in love and then they died and I
was seriously amazing of the Titanic I
would bet $500
that that was at least bought brought up
at a meeting somewhere even even if
everybody else at the meeting was like
nah dude that's the stupidest idea I've
ever heard but I I kind of feel like
they don't say that enough though
because I don't what here's the thing
I've seen some moves like I've seen a
lot of great movies too and like I said
I don't I'm not like a negative person I
really liked like [ __ ] on movies for
sure and seeing them and stuff like that
but there are some movies out there that
you're like wow I can't believe a movie
with that concept actually got made that
they actually like put millions of
dollars into that and stuff like that so
I always wonder if those actually got
made
what were the ones that didn't get made
were they good or were they even worse
than that I don't know see this is what
I kind of suspect that there were
probably good movies and then people
were just like now yeah let's let's make
volcano tarantulas three the quickening
or you know what I mean it's like let's
make that yeah instead and then like
here's like this well they did wait like
what they did to the Highlander property
Trail Highlander one was alright it
should just left it the [ __ ] alone yeah
and then it stopped it started to make
less and less sense and get more and
more ridiculous because Highlander 1 was
ridiculous enough really what do you
think yeah and like you said it's just
hard to recapture yeah it's like I I can
almost understand when they make like
when they made the Lost Boys for example
87 it was very successful it kind of
became kind of a cultural meme like I
said people still remember [ __ ] the
vampire movie what we do in the shadows
from 2014 directly referenced a scene
from this movie so it's still obviously
like a big cultural touchstone so I can
see maybe a year or two later them
talking about making a sequel I'm not
saying it was a good idea I'm just
saying I can see that the weird thing to
me is that they made a sequel 20 years
later they're writing years later
running out of [ __ ] to do it just seems
like if you're gonna do a secret right
away you should do it right away like a
year or two later yeah three years met
that movie would have taken a long time
to make yeah I mean you know it's just a
level of filmography the photography of
the thing
you know it was visually yeah look cool
you know you have to write a good story
and I think he went on to I think that
director went on to do something right
after this didn't he well he did
Flatliners three years after this so I'm
not sure if it was his next project or
there was another one in there in
between probably went right on a flat I
think it might have been flat liners and
maybe that's why cuz he liked working
with Kiefer Sutherland so much that you
know that he got him in Flatliners one
day he was very good in that - over the
doors movie yeah what year did that come
out late 80s or early 90s I think that
92 92 I want to say 992 I think I just
got out of high as much as they tried to
do a sequel to that zombie Jim Morrison
will bring him back from the dead
I'm sure that was discussed also yeah
now we're gonna bring Jim bag you know
what we should do a whole entire episode
I'd have to think about it for a while
we should do a whole entire episode of
like movies that totally shouldn't have
sequels but we'll like pitch a sequel
for a movie that totally shouldn't have
this right yes that would be hilarious
yeah but I would have to like think
about it like Brazil right it's like
it's like anything that it's like no
there's no possible way they could make
a sequel to this movie yeah but we'll
think of one right you know what I mean
it's like I I would love that now I'm
gonna like the story outline of that
what I'm saying it's even if it's just
like an elevator pitch it's just it
doesn't have to be like a whole outline
it could just be like a couple sentences
of just like you know this happens like
I said with the tight and it like a
Titanic yeah thing it's ridiculous but
what equal to Romeo and Juliet right
it's like what if somebody said I'll
give you thirty million dollars to write
a sequel to Titanic or to write a sequel
to the doors movie or something like
that and you have to come up with
something what would you come up with
yeah oh I love this I love this secret
the sequel to the yellow submarine job
that wasn't even a movie in itself not
really like a series begin hi vignettes
inspired by acid
I just didn't really make any narrative
sense but yeah holy crap I know what the
conversations gonna be like for the rest
of the day I'm just gonna be coming up
with movies it totally shouldn't have
stapled like I said this one seemed like
you know you could expand that universe
could Santa Carla the town was supposed
to be like overrun with vampires yes
they killed the head vampire yes they
killed him the gangs but there could
have been other ones because it was like
a lot of murders there was a lot of kids
missing and [ __ ] like that
so that universe could be expanded and
like I said they did it with the comic
books and whatnot but I don't know it's
a the first movie was just so iconic
with the cast particularly the
soundtrack it's like the whole look of
it you know I you just can't
recapture that like you said and I think
that's hard to do for any movie that
made such a big like cultural impact and
particularly something that's so like
emblematic of the year that it came out
I mean this is so 87 I think that's why
movies are gonna vanish it's either
gonna be a video game or it's gonna be a
series because it's hard to make a story
like this happen in a two hour time
frame everything's been done already
pretty much pretty much I always I've
always been of the opinion that if
you're going to like adapt something to
a movie I think it's better to adapt a
short story to movie like yeah if you're
gonna adopt adapt a novel you need to
see the series right because otherwise
you're just taking so much [ __ ] out and
it's just like what's the point of it
like make it into a series even a
miniseries you know it could just be
like three or four episodes really like
that but I think short stories would
work better it work better as movies if
you're just gonna adapt it yeah because
that's what you need to do it's just
kind of like what Dark Tower sucked so
bad how does it hell are you gonna
there's that book into a damn movie and
like I said I mean that's a whole series
of books that's not even just one book
yeah but even that first book you
couldn't put that into one movie no
there's a movie being eight hours long
and I think like I said this is probably
a situation where they call up some poor
screenwriter it was like hey we want to
turn the dark tower into a movie and
he's like are you [ __ ] me and we're
like no seriously you have to do it
we'll give you thirty million dollars
and he was like
okay I'll come up with something where
they turn the talisman into a movie into
it yeah yeah like I said there's just no
some of that [ __ ] there's just no way
you could do it yeah there's just no way
to get to it but like I said if you're
gonna adapt something adapt short story
yeah but you know so vampire movies in
the 80s like I said we covered one last
week Fright Night which everybody needs
to see you also need to see this one
this is like the rock-and-roll vampire
the movie 80s and it's a must-see and
yeah spawned a lot of the kind of cool
vampire [ __ ] that came later
particularly Buffy the Vampire Slayer
and some of the other vampire series
that everybody will make if you're facin
era they make you want to jump and damn
TARDIS and go back yeah I remember that
it kind of does yeah cuz I remember when
a world was like that yeah cuz this is
very like I said this is very free
internet and all nostalgic for this
because I remember when people dress
like that I remember no cellphones
I remember having that soundtrack I
remember that whole Gestalt of the thing
yeah but yeah seriously
comic book stores from back in the day
oh I just you know what I read that was
a real comic book store that they filmed
that in it got destroyed two years later
in an earthquake
okay although the owner reopened it
somewhere else right so and he still has
that cover that said vampires everywhere
he's like that wasn't a real can you
remember that free internet era when
people were very easily entertained yeah
you know they could just go walk around
and we did yeah well drink and make it
can't make a little campfire and try to
have group sex on you some bridge and
not succeed oh god people [ __ ]
watching out for the cops
[Laughter]
yeah that's sneaking some alcohol out of
your parents yep
cabinet yeah or just or just hiring the
winos to go buy it
we had balls say hey man good oh yeah
look you guys actually hired why hire
two damn winos to go do it man that's
very enterprise thankin right yeah they
knew all the best places yet you walk up
to him like Danny Way you looking for
some you look at yeah we're looking for
something and then you
you go what do you want that one okay
you get that but get us this and then
get us it and get yourself a ice wish
you're sweet you know and [ __ ] like that
yeah cuz then you want to pack of
cigarettes and then alright I got a
dollar I'll be back I'm gonna be here
next week you know the custom you make a
run for you don't want you an over there
that's pretty sweet I never even thought
of that
yeah you gotta find an honest bum like a
dumb ass we always like tried to just
find the oldest person look at the
oldest looking person see the mistake a
lot of mistake a lot a lot of dudes made
back then is that they would walk up on
those bums in a crowd four or five of
them yeah and it tracks too much
detention yeah you gotta send one kid up
to him say hey man you wanna make some
money oh yeah if they get like a whole
gang of kids coming up think they're
gonna get their ass kicked
well not only that is just as to me damn
witnesses and the people people what
people are watching and it might be a
cop sting or something you know that's
just one kid and you know you couldn't
and you're always taking the risk that
they'll rip you off but we never got
ripped off see we never got ripped off
honest yeah that's pretty bad though
yeah yeah I know you looking for
something I know you looking for
something you know that because they're
hanging out there well the thing is they
probably hang out those same places and
it's like do that if they [ __ ] people
over then they don't get score again we
had we had a regular guy exactly had a
guy we probably hit that dude about five
six and they'll get their ass kicked
probably because they'll people will see
them like in the same spots all the time
yep so you just have to go to know what
part of town there's no incentive for
them kid do that in a good part of town
you gotta go to the rough part of town
where the winos are that's that's like
you go to where the waters are yeah oh
boy we're gonna play you gotta happen to
that have money getting her bicep I'm
cigarettes and damn cigars and you know
that way they can restock themselves
yeah and they go Toronto seven wins a
win win then they're gonna donate you
know they're gonna sell some of that too
yeah but you know I like it but you had
like five six guys you know chipping in
20 bucks each we have money yeah yeah
now say it going here and make a big old
score
nice use iMeet you aware I mean you know
whatever
okay oh yeah like that I'll meet you
where nanobot and hope Oh sounds kind of
like your dad that's kind of like when
you do your dad's voice and out of it
well he's my dad just sound like that
because they had pulled his heart out
well yeah and replace it with turkey
necks for all you regular listeners if
you've just tuned in you have no idea
we're talking where's my gun
time to fight his way out the hospital
it was gonna be a hostage what he
thought he'd been abducted he's kind of
yeah where's my truck you trying to
escape
ah his drugs well yeah I guess so
wrap it up wrap it up go see the Lost
Boys if you haven't seen it you may read
it for YouTube on 399 just like for a
399 just like we did and yeah so we'll
see you next time bye
what bless you